today's one minute monday is it's a  marathon  running the business is not a sprint  it's a marathon and things take time to  happen  no matter how hard you work no matter  how much effort you put in at the  beginning it still will take time and  you need to let time for that momentum  to build and too many entrepreneurs they  don't see results right away do you  think it's going to be easy  you don't see results right away and so  you quit  it's way better to spend one hour a day  but one hour every single day doing  something to grow your business  than to cram everything in  to a couple weeks see no results and  quit and go get a job  it's a marathon it's not a sprint make  sure you allow for time to build all  your momentum up and do something every  day to grow your company  believe  if you like this video give it a thumbs  up leave a comment below my giveaway  response thank you so much and i'll see  you soon